lexandre langlois les secrétaire général
du syndicat végépolys ça monsieur
l'envoi bonjour merci à d'être avec vous
voulez rebondir sur les propos d'un de
nos invités qu'on a eu tout à l'heure
monsieur boyer c'est un soutien de la
famille d'adama traoré il souligne que
toutes ces manifestations ne sont pas
contre la police au contraire de la
police on en a besoin on aura toujours
besoin
il souligne que la famille d'adama
traoré et là parfait elle veut connaître
la vérité
une soeur qui cherche à comprendre
pourquoi son frère est mort c'est un peu
normal mais c'est normal après
effectivement en général les
manifestations organisées par ce
collectif et c'est tout à leur honneur
se déroule bien en général n'y a pas de
débordements dans la plupart des cas
donc tant mieux qu'il continue ainsi
d'après effectivement nous on prend ça
plus une manifestation contre la justice
parce que la justice en fait c'est elle
qui instruit le dossier depuis quatre
ans et c'est là que ça n'avance pas
hélas hélas on peut dire citizen
miscibles que la justice prenne tant de
temps en france pour arriver et ça
permettrait de calmer tout le monde en
fait d'avoir des réponses et de qu'on
puisse passer à autre chose pour tout le
monde alors il faut contextualisant pour
qu'on comprenne bien en fait il y déjà
les premières expertises et concluant
que le pronostic vital d'adama traoré
était engagé de façon irréversible en
fait qu'il était déjà malade avant son
interpellation de là la famille demande
d'autres expertises des médecins des
professeurs de pitau parisot qui
contredisent les premières expertises en
fait on a des versions qui divergent on
peut se poser des questions c'est normal
selon vous à baky les opinions qui
peuvent diverger oui ça peut être
possible les spécialistes sont divers et
variés chacun arrive à des conclusions
différentes et apprécier le travail de
la justice de se baser sur toutes ses
conclusions pour se faire son idée
essayer de découvrir ce qui est le plus
proche de la vérité donc et des
expertises et des contre expertises qui
soit pas forcément d'accord bas le mythe
on va continuer de j'espère qu'ils la
justice de pouvoir continuer de
travailler jusqu'à temps que d'avoir la
réponse réelle à ce qui s'est passé
alors les finalement oui à les dialysés
parce que finalement on était personne
n'était sur place donc après on peut
toujours refaire le match pendant des
années mais sur place ce qui s'est passé
s'est déroulée en pas très longtemps
finalement par rapport au temps que la
justice a derrière donc effectivement
prenons le temps pour trouver la vérité
mais après il faut aussi que la justice
ait les moyens d'avoir des expertises
dont elle a besoin alors en tout cas les
experts s'accordent sur une chose adama
traoré est mort d'un syndrome asphyxique
aiguë alors est ce que c'est à cause des
pressions effectuées par les gendarmes à
ce que c'est parce qu'il était malade
avant ça on sais pas peut-être qu'on le
saura un jour pour autant pour éviter ce
genre de situation est ce qui serait pas
plus judicieux d'éviter ce genre de
technique les clé d'étranglement le
placage antral dans le plaquage ventrale
oui ça ce serait bien de l'éviter après
je tiens à préciser comme juste
également c'est que laisser des
gendarmes qui ont agi sur cette
interpellation et les gendarmes ont des
techniques militaires par rapport à la
police qu aider d'autres techniques nous
ne sommes pas régis par les mêmes codes
dépendent aussi du code de la défense et
pas les policiers donc après sur le
placage central au niveau de la police
effectivement on pourrait trouver
d'autres méthodes que cette méthode
puisque effectivement elle est
dangereuse et n'apportent pas de plus
value opérationnel après pour la
technique d'extrêmement elle peut être
utile dans certains cas donc un pâtit
toujours une question de formation parce
que effectivement dans certains cas il
ya des gens qui sont un maîtrisable et
la seule façon de les maîtriser
c'est de les faire tomber dans les
pommes en les asphyxiant légèrement j'ai
des collègues m'ont raconté des
interventions avec des gens qui étaient
complètement shooté au crack qui
mesurait deux mètres c'était des
golgoths ils ont dit on ne peut rien
faire et quel que soit le sport de
combat qu'on fasse donc sur un sport de
combat d'attac qui sera encore plus
violent on ne peut rien faire et leur
tirer dessus n'est pas la solution
donc il ya certains cas où ça peut être
utile par contre ça doit pas être
banalisé généralisée par facilité et par
manque de moyens de personnel et de
cadrage de formation de façon générale
donc en fait un problème institutionnel
où l'institution pour des raisons
économiques le choisi cette technique
pour éviter d'avoir tout un panel des
formations et des gens sur le terrain
alors cette affaire met en lumière les
problèmes qui peut avoir entre les
policiers une certaine partie de la
population ce que vous pensez
on avance vers du mieux en ce moment
alors sa voie il ya toujours une partie
de la population qui nous a pas aimé a
évidemment ces deux délinquants et
criminels et cela on ne pourra rien
faire par contre les gens qui veulent
vivre tranquillement qui sont victimes
selon eux de de violence policière
illégale parce qu'effectivement nous
devons des fois aussi utiliser la
violence pour établir l'ordre pour faire
respecter la loi et une c'est nécessaire
et la pelouse de la population nous a
délégué la force publique
après ce qu'on peut aller en mieux oui
alors bien sûr sur les discours soient
claires il tombe pas dans la polémique
et malheureusement l'époque actuelle
fait que souvent ce qu'on retient des
discours de chaque côté
si nous on essaye de ne pas rentrer dans
ce cas page là c'est ben forcément quand
il ya quelqu'un de couleurs qui tue et
ciron en amont crient au racisme qui est
blessé dans une intervention de police
ont cru racisme sans savoir si la
personne est un acte délictuels ou
criminels et même chose nous avons des
syndicats de police de l'autre côté qui
est des caprices et fait quelque chose
il est forcément innocent parce qu les
policiers malheureusement les dents de
la polémique on est dans la surenchère
plutôt que de se baser sur des faits et
d'avoir le recul calme pour analyser
chaque situation non par rapport parce
que la personne est de couleur ou parce
que la personne et policiers et parce
qu'il ya des faits qu'il faut étudier
il ne faut pas trouver dans les séries
générales et à l'heure actuelle
malheureusement il ya beaucoup de chaque
côté malheureusement qui ne sont pas du
côté de l'apaisement
donc ce serait bien comme l'autre jour
il ya un champion de boxe thaï qui a
fait cette analyse également nous
saluons parce que ça permet
effectivement d'aller dans le bon sens
du dialogue et de se baser à chaque fois
sur chaque situation qui est différente
sur déchets par rapport à la loi
française alexandre langlois merci
d'avoir été en direct avec nous sur rt
france je rappelle que vous êtes
secrétaire général du syndicat vigie au
10 mars